[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
okay so if you love home team podcasts
with when uh we just talk about issues
different topics you're getting what you
asked for today we have Adam in the
house Tyler's best friend today we have
Jedediah in the house and Tom's uh in
the house as well the biz Doc and we got
a lot of stuff to talk hello guys a lot
of things Tom's got some new charts to
talk about business-wise I got a few
things to talk about in regards to the
economy Jets got some things to say
about hokel New York Liz truss
apparently texted something to Tyler who
did she text to a secretary of state
Anthony blinking and seven minutes done
10 minutes after the Nordstrom Nordstrom
pipeline was uh hid she says it's done
10 minutes later which is kind of weird
and the next thing you know she resigns
that quickly little weird we'll talk
about that uh Russia says UK Navy blew
up north stream pipeline Again part of
that story we're gonna bring in our
friend uh oil expert uh he's gonna be
awesome he'll be on like at the later
half for like 10 30 if you really want
to know what's going on that's his world
he's going to give us a little bit of
insight we'll talk musk we'll talk
Twitter Adam wants to talk Connie and
maybe we'll talk a little bit about a b
and a few other things that's going on
Tom's got one topic of sports Aaron
judge he wants to talk about because Tom
has a prediction of where he believes
Aaron judge will go next and it's
definitely not the Yankees I'll let him
tell you that okay so a b interview
after was done did you watch it yourself
again or no you haven't done the whole
thing yeah no you haven't seen that's
the whole thing did you watch anything
you want to go crazy again so it was on
Sports illustrator picked it up New York
Post it was bar stool Fox it was Daily
Mail did you see the clip a b made about
me on Twitter as a hoax as a not a hoax
as a uh a parody
a Freudian slip the road yeah we had a
good time Bill man but of of anything he
could have said about you he made sort
of like a gay reference or what was that
joke yeah to say when I date guys is
what he said
he's up there with troll status all you
know major troll stuff I don't think
he's on Jake Paul Elon Musk troll stuff
let me tell you what he did he's going
there let me tell you what he did do he
made me watch CT videos all weekend long
and I had Dylan and Tico watch a few
videos on CT I will tell you that just
so we can get a little bit uh Smarter on
what uh uh how it happens different
sports that happens the consequences how
to prepare for it if you can if you
can't choices you got to make so it
caused us to have some real
conversations in the house uh about
sports CT is the real issue I mean look
at Biden
out of anything you took from the
interview you're focusing more on CTE
yeah because everything else you know
look the the most sensitive topic to him
was CTE yeah it was the most sensitive
topic to him which means you know
sometimes you fear something you don't
want people to bring it up and you keep
bringing it up because that's what you
fear to me he fears that maybe something
happened and I watched a clip of him
getting hit again it's a it's a
disturbing hit yeah it's a disturbing
hit I actually have a different
perspective on that because I've had a
chance to really sort of recalibrate of
what he was why he was so focused on the
CTE thing
so let's just play Devil's Advocate that
he does not have CTE because if he would
have just sort of clarified his biggest
problem is that that you could give sort
of a nuanced here's my opinion in in 10
seconds or less or you can just become
argumentative and spend a half hour just
kind of bsing your point ultimately all
he had to say was this two things number
one I've lost many many good friends
counterparts wide receivers specifically
Vincent Jackson who was the other one
that he referenced
um there was Vincent Jackson he
mentioned Junior SEO Jr linebacker there
was another wide receiver uh Demaryius
Thomas okay these are people that played
his exact position at the exact same
time that were exactly pro bowlers like
him so there's definitely an emotional
component like guys I know at my
position at this Elite level died of CTE
so he didn't Express that
like poignantly enough to say that's why
this is so insensitive to me number two
all he had to say was this bro I don't
know if I have it or I don't have it I
don't want it but you're not gonna know
until I'm dead so you're essentially
wanting me to die to find out and I
think that's why you become so emotional
about something like this but
don't judge me and assume I have it and
judge my actions by it there was a
single in there like that but you're
pre-judging it you don't even know
exactly and then and then obviously it's
a sensitive topic but I'm gonna give him
the uh you know benefit of the benefit
of the doubt that he does not have
freaking CTE but is a very sensitive
topic to him and he does not do an
amazing job of expressing why he feels
so strongly about it so that's my two
cents on yeah you know the one part when
you watch him and you watch Kanye I
thought he was trying to talk like Kanye
but he's not Kanye you can't copy
creative genius you know Kanye in the
creative side you forget about his
opinions about whatever he has as a
creative he's a genius and a lot of time
when you try to copy creative genius
you're gonna feel it's not easy to do
it's impossible to duplicate creative
genius there's only one of one anybody
you think of that's super super creative
they're one of one you don't have seven
versions of a musk right you don't have
six versions of a Kanye you don't have
you know 18 versions of it's one of one
and like he's trying to be somebody he's
not well like you said like oh you want
to go be the next Andrew Tate best of
luck homie go try to duplicate what
Andrew take does the way he talks the
way he acts is Pedigree his background
everything he's been through not gonna
happen here you go somebody just
commented the Super Chat PVD I'm going
through a new uh test now for CT it's
not just from football although I did
play uh mine is from getting beat in the
head have a great day okay all right so
listen there's a there's a lot of ways
to get CTS for soccer is one of them by
the way but look before we get into all
these topics sorry we get into all these
topics yeah good you want to finish I
don't want to make the whole a b two
hour interview about CTE I guess you
asked for my final thoughts what I will
say is I think you did a him a very good
service of saying don't judge the full
interview by the first hour watch the
entire interview to get a full
perspective on this guy I happen to
believe he showed up drunk
I think he was a little [ __ ] up high
showed up and then like he was the way
that you introduced him actually wasn't
that bad but he made it an issue he kind
of came in argumentative but I think as
like when we literally took off the
headphones and we're like listen we
don't have to do this we're doing this
because we would like to we you could
leave right now I think you know he put
down his guard we all put down our guard
and like cooler heads prevailed and the
second half of the interview we truly
had a a very informal like almost like f
off-camera dialogue and I think that was
the real him yeah well do you agree
prepared for the tension like it was it
was watching it I was like whoa you know
I didn't were you prepared for that to
go in a wild Direction and what would
you have done if like were you prepared
for the option of let's say it was like
I'm out of here like do you ever think
about that going into it no it's not a
problem he had a bodyguard sitting right
there another guy sitting right there
and you know every time he would say
stuff he would look over there at one
point he got up like ready to if things
were going to get heated oh wow and I
got up he thought I was getting to leave
I got up because I was getting water
from the corner but uh no there was a
there was a couple moments where I said
this thing can go any direction it was
like oh you have asking me questions you
acting like a girl you acting like a
girlfriend
there's just a lot of back and forth and
I was at him but uh I thought it was a
great interview I appreciate him for
coming out the audience gets to choose
for themselves how they want to judge
him or us or if there was any Clarity
that came out of it I was trying to get
something out of it for Brady just so
you know right after the video came out
six hours later he put up one of his new
shirts online did you see that one that
has to do with divorce attorney call me
for divorce attorney you know again
taking a shot at him so he's going it's
obviously he's doubling down on whatever
he believed in there is no let me
reposition myself last Point Pat last
point this is what I think and people
want authentic real people real
conversations and I think that's what
we're doing here here on valuetainment I
think it's on a lot of podcasts are
doing and I think that's what people
want because imagine if our interview
with a B was 10 minutes quick quick
quick quick quick quick quick quick
quick you're not going to really
understand somebody you're not going to
really get to the the heart of the
matter and I think that's why an hour
two hour podcast is so important yeah
especially in today's culture like
whether it's debates like we all have
our issues with presidential debates or
obviously see what's going on it's sound
bites but you really get to know people
more when you can fully express yourself
over the course all I know is the
weirdest people texted me apparently the
weirdest people texted you as well about
their interviews people people haven't
talked to for a longest time sending me
a message saying how the hell did you
guys sit through that you know Etc et
cetera but it is what it is so okay for
some of you guys that don't know who ABS
is Antonio Brown played in the NFL was a
teammate of Tom Brady left posted some
pictures about himself and Gisele which
is Tom's ex right after they announced
the divorce so his timing of trying to
be a troll wasn't uh the best of timing
or it was intentional so that's why we
invited them to have the conversation
with them anyways before we get into all
these topics we got a lot of topics to
get through it's the 200 episode that we
have let me give a shout out to our
sponsor real quick which is Aura Aura is
somebody that now is also sponsoring
your show which you you had a test
yourself to find out how many of your
password they were being used in the
dark but what number did you find number
44. 44 44 times your password was being
compromised yeah so if you don't know
this folks the the fastest growing crime
in America today is identity theft it's
happening all the time it's happened to
me this is why we do these types of
things where we bring a sponsor like
this and every 14 seconds it happens
last year cost Americans 52 billion
dollars just last year it's officially
the number one crime in America ahead of
robbery and this has happened in
regularly we have people that went in
here that took the test as well to see
how many of their passports being used
or not you can do the same yourself if
you go and take the test and for those
of you guys that are part of the content
you follow valuting you follow pbd
podcast you're going to get a 50 a free
a free 14-day trial all you need to do
is go to aura.com forward slash pbd once
again Aura a u r a.com forward slash pbd
aura.com forward slash pbd go find out
how many times your personal information
is being used on the dark web it is a
must because if you do go through this
mess it's ugly it's annoying it's the
last thing you want to deal with having
said that let's get right into a Tom
tell us how you feel about the economy
right now I looked at the Dow the Dow is
up you know everybody's like oh the
Market's recovering the Market's
recovering the Market's coming back up
and then you're seeing 32 000 something
on the dial you know this is all a bunch
of BS unemployment is down Market's
doing fine why are people so worried
about what's going on with the economy
what do you see on uh currently going on
with the economy well given that we pump
so much dollars into it asset prices are
inflated and one of those assets is
equities right stocks stocks and
companies and when you take a look at
what's going on right now you have A
Tale of Two Cities happening all over
the stock market it's not a barometer of
what the average American and what
America is facing economically for
example Snapchat down 90 for the year
oil and gas stocks up 35 40 percent for
what it was depending on who you talk to
I don't think that's up the full sector
I think the full sector is like 17 or 20
or something like that but still you've
got sectors that are up that Dow is not
what is happening in America the Dow is
merely the stock market and when you
pump so many dollars into it this is why
so many asset classes like trading cards
artwork gold and a lot of things were up
because the housing prices over the year
those are all assets and so a stock what
America needs to think about if you're
listening think of a stock as a house
that's overpriced and that makes the Dow
be really high think of it as what
you're hearing about on artwork and
trading cards which if you own them and
you bought them two years ago you're in
a really good place you know you may
want to get out sooner than later but
that's what's there the average American
is facing uh the inflation that still
hasn't changed you go take pictures of
the gas stations in California and it's
not a um
it's not a narrative story so you're not
going to see the mainstream but
Californians are still suffering with
energy causes and pricing at the pump
and you go straight to the back of the
store and look at the price of eggs in a
gallon of milk the average America in
that shopping basket and what they have
to buy electricity gas the inflation is
still there and it's hard on them and so
when you see the stock market and all
the celebration just remember those
little stocks or assets just like
housing and trading cards and they're
overpriced I want to show you a couple
charts here that I got okay uh let's
start off with this one here so check
this out this is from 2009 till today
green represents all items orange
represents food look how much prices
have increased from 2020. go from
election right there from 2020 look
what's happened to food and all items
skyrocketed all the way to the top this
is the worst we've had in many years so
who feels this if you're going shopping
you go to the market you're feeling it
Jennifer comes back and tells me babe
prices are higher I used to spend this
much and I'm spending this much go to
the next one if you look at the economy
today median weekly earnings as weird as
it sounds it peaked at 2020 when the
election was taking place the moment
Biden got elected look what happened to
median weekly earnings dropped this is
again these are sources that I'm reading
from Bureau of Labor Statistics this
isn't CNN this isn't MSNBC this isn't
Fox this is purely coming from the
source so things are more expensive
income is lower for full-time worker go
to the next one
consumer sentiment Index this shows how
confident they're like the the more it
is in the blue the better it is which
means if it's in the blue if it's higher
that President's going to get re-elected
they don't typically not get reelected
unfortunately the only one that didn't
get reelected was the one that shows
Trump because according to history
typically if consumer sentiment index is
high that President gets reelected but
watch what happened after 2022 go to the
next one here's what's happened since
2022 since 2020. it's the lowest it's
been even lower than 2008 when you look
at that which means the CH if you're a
betting man do not bet on somebody on
the left to win if you're purely going
to Las Vegas too bad that red is the
lowest it's been and by the way look at
the source this is University of
Michigan that you're not talking about
Liberty from Michigan this is University
of Michigan this isn't Hillsdale College
this is University of Michigan flat out
telling you what's about to happen in a
next election and go to the last one
Consumer Price Index this is last 40
years okay like what that looks like
inflation that that is not an exciting
thing to be looking at okay I had a guy
call me from La uh uh and him and I are
having this conversation together he
says look do you have any interest of
ever getting to the mortgage business
I'm like are you serious he's the top
mortgage guy in LA in Glendale he says
do you have any interest again to the
mortgage business and I said I'm good
man I don't have any interest in
business stuff but you don't have one
that's doing so well you can make so
much cash I'm not interested in cash I'm
interested in equity I'm interested in
building the company
so he says the following to me flat out
what I liked about him is he had zero he
says Pat I don't care what anybody's
telling you this is a different guy than
the other guy I spoke to he says
mortgage refi business is down 90
percent
90 is down we're doing no refi's we're
doing none of that stuff do you have the
Yahoo finance article about Las Vegas
how Las Vegas Board of realty they asked
them they said so what's happening with
because you know the way to judge it is
to find out the board of Realty in each
city and state and how they're doing and
a lot of times they judge it based on
Las Vegas so watch this article here if
you can zoom in a little bit more so we
can read it a little bit more a little
bit more okay housing market active this
is from six days ago housing market
activity is crashing and it threatens to
push us into recession just like it did
in 81 in 2008 now go up
if you look at the data we're talking
there you go in the middle zoom in a
little bit Las Vegas is one of the
leading indicators for home price action
in the housing market like we saw in
2008 and the frenzy uh recent frenzy we
are absolutely feeling the heat here the
buyer pool has for the most part dried
up says real estate agent in Las Vegas
to uh Fortune go a little lower go a
little lower because now they're talking
go keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going story continues keep
going keep going keep going uh right
there right there Realtors are feeling
it big time as well I put a call into
the greater Las Vegas Association of
Realtors an employee I spoke with said
that they are averaging uh they were
averaging 300 new members every month
which means like 300 new Realtors uh
every month this month she has estimated
120 however she's been processing about
30 realtor withdrawals a day not a week
a day that's 900 negative I'm a month
time wow that means every day around 30
real estate agents in Las Vegas alone
are calling it quits okay and if if you
go a little lower she'll talk about the
fact that 38 is down uh look for the
number 38 keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going uh uh
anyways there's a 38 number about what's
happened with the refi business so uh
it's a very interesting Market we're in
right now different economies are
feeling that people are feeling it but a
lot of times people are who don't want
to talk about what's really going on
with the market all they're talking
about is unemployment and the
unemployment numbers are going to be
felt next year not this year person
asked me question on Twitter and Jed you
were asking me this question I'll say
this and then we'll toss it around to
recipe guys is this a good time to buy
and my advice is very simple if you're
thinking about buying a house today buy
a house today but make the offer you
would make a year from today so if
you're buying a million dollar home make
a 770 offer if you're buying a 600 000
home make a 490 offer if you're buying a
450 000 condo or home in certain parts
of the country May AKA 370 offer but do
not make the offer you would make in
today's economy because there's still
room I believe for these values to go
down the next 12 to 18 months yeah
Zillow is showing you know this is the
the average run-up of the last year and
so we don't want to say the address or
anything on here but you can take a look
at that Pat you see that lump that
Skyrocket right there over the last 12
months is an illusion so you have five
years of some modest growth two to three
percent just growing along see there and
all of a sudden Wham we print money the
asset changes so let's go take a look at
this house what was it uh you know
October of 21.
uh
uh 1.3 yeah so right now it's at 1.8 it
was 1.3 and then go back to October 20.
there it is so if you were gonna go buy
this house right now you would go go in
there and say probably 1.1 you know
exactly what I'd be making a million
that's exactly your advice Pat is
absolutely true I look at it I look at
it this way I I did a little research
for some numbers for some basic numbers
I'll do this really quick right now
let's say someone is buying a 500 000
house just that's it and you're going to
do a 30-year fixed and you're going to
put 20 down so standard standard deal
in March of this year you would have had
a three and a half percent mortgage or
an eighteen hundred dollar payment
reasonable you know for a family
right now at 7.5 percent
that's twenty eight hundred dollars up a
thousand dollars at
ten point two five percent where you and
I both think this is going it's double
thirty six hundred dollars oh it's going
there so the buyers are are being
crossed now let's go the other way let's
say the 1800 was all that I could afford
as a buyer when the interest rates at
7.5 the 500 000 house I can afford I can
only afford a 325
000 house so my buying power is down
almost 40 percent so what you have right
now if you are out there and you have to
change jobs you're being forced to go to
another city right now I would seriously
consider not dumping the house you have
lease the house you have because
you're going you're not going to be able
to sell it right now you're you're and
the the price is going to come back down
but where you're going the interest
rates are so high so if you sell where
do you go and what do you buy your your
payments you know you know what confuses
me is the final one those who are
delusional because they're in the
industry and they're saying that's not
going to happen there's a very big
difference between power of positive
thinking and not understanding that the
only the paranoid survive I believe you
should read both books simultaneously
read the book power of positive thinking
because it's good to have a positive
attitude but do not be delusional
because you're in real estate and
mortgage is thinking no it's not going
to happen your ago rates were roughly
2.9 percent in May when Dave Ramsey
called it fear porn the rates were at
five percent and today rates are seven
and a half percent for 30 year interest
interest and everyone's saying it's not
going to go to seven and a half never
what are you talking about do you
realize from 1981 or 82 I don't know
what their year was for about nine years
straight interest rates in America were
above 10 percent can you pull that up
please do you realize 14 this is the
part where people are absolutely
delusional go to the rates I sent you no
it was one that just showed the charts
there you go that's the one yeah this is
Paul volcker's endless Halloween so
check this out zoom in zoom in so
everybody can see let's first look at
the first chart to the right which what
we've been used to for the last 20 years
yeah go to the right no no don't worry
about the stuff on the left okay so what
is it right now Gola lore Cola lore lore
okay 2021 2.96
the 2010 three three nine four five
three nine three six three eight four
one three nine three six oh rates are
cool this is what we're used to this is
BS This Is A Lie four four four six five
this is a lie then it's real 666 keep
going 6.3 6.4 go to twenty uh 2005.
to okay five eight five eight five eight
these are numbers that we need to stay
around six five six nine eight now watch
this is two thousand we're at eight
seven four six nine seven six seven
eight seven nine eight three seven three
four straight decade it's around seven
plus right now you got 1990 just 32
years ago it's at 10.13 it'll never
crack ten percent it won't happen Okay
go to 1989 let's look at 89. NOW Watch
What Happens so that's two years three
years four years five six seven eight
nine ten eleven keep going eleven twelve
twelfth strike yours thirty year fixed
rates were above ten percent let me say
this one more time for 12 straight years
30-year mortgage rates were above ten
percent and people are saying it's not
going to go to ten percent brace for
impact folks read power of positive
thinking and read only the paranoid
survive long term everything's gonna be
fine short term these rates are gonna
get to 10 points I hope I'm wrong but
leave me because I'm trying to also
participate okay I've taken a hit on a
few the properties I bought I hope I'm
wrong but it's going this direction
and right now it's really interesting
also right now today I think it was uh
Diana Olek on CNBC reported she's the um
uh real estate reporter tends to be
pretty balanced not sold out to the
industry
um the listings are up 36 percent year
or year so listings are coming on right
now as sellers are trying to get in a
certain class of seller trying to get in
and sell the house to somebody God
please somebody buy my house right now
and you have the interest rates here so
I think that the last we've had the
interest rates go up we've had the
housing start stall we've had the
purchases from Builders like Toll
Brothers saying nobody's walking in to
buy so they're stuck with inventory all
of those things have happened the next
thing is about to happen price just
think of supply and demand the supply is
up 36 percent over last year yet the
buyers have lost 34 percent of their
buying power the next shoe to drop is
the price and I used to say hey I've
been saying hanging if people been
listening to the podcast you've heard me
talk about real estate and economy
saying next June now I'm saying next
October so I was looking at beginning of
Q2 now I'm looking at the beginning of
Q3 where I think that window is going to
be open where the rates are going to be
coming back a little bit and you're
going to have an opportunity but between
now and then you're gonna have to if
you've got to move then you don't put
yourself in a bad purchase find a way to
lease lease a lot less and just get
through the storm think about this
people's minds though going into these
midterms I mean all of these topics we
just talked about buyers stressed out
renters by the way very stressed out
because the rental market and a lot of
these desirable places including places
like Florida rents have gone up people
go to the grocery store they can't
afford the prices of goods and services
inflation has been probably the biggest
thing that people can actually feel
tangibly every day as you said with your
wife at the grocery store there's all
these headlines that say the recession
is coming and people are like we're not
there yet I'm feeling every day like I'm
struggling they are already feeling like
they're there and now they're thinking
well if the bad's not here yet what's
that going to look like for me and my
family and I think the only hope for
people is a shift in politics they look
and they say okay is there going to be a
shift here that's going to change things
the midterms I think will be a GOP
pretty pretty intensive sweep we're
going to see I mean it's even
interesting to look at the New York race
I don't know how many people are
following hokel and um Lee zeldin but
Lee zeldon is actually in the lead the
Republican in some polling there it's
insane you see that happening insane and
New York City a race should never be
that close right so there's going to be
a shift but then people look and say
well if there's a shift in the midterm
sometimes then there's backlash in the
next presidential election against the
midterm so I just feel the stress of
people all the time and when I get you
know reach out from people on social
media they're always like where what do
people do who don't have a cushion you
know it's one thing to go through times
like this when you have a cushion what
if you're you don't have that you've got
your one home and you're trying to
relocate and you you do need to sell it
like there's just too much going on that
people feel like they're backed into a
corner and I think ultimately though I
think stock market aside all that aside
I think is going to be the price of
goods and services because you can't get
from today to tomorrow if you can't pay
for the stuff that's in the grocery
store and put gas in your car that's
going to be the leading issue the
inflationary issue and I don't know what
Democrats are going to say when you look
going into these midterms I mean we're
very close it's coming up next week I
don't know what they could possibly say
that would go against the reality that
people are facing I mean the reality is
people are hurting and when people are
hurting they want to change regardless
whether you know you can put all the
blame on the Democrats or what they're
going to say let's change something
maybe that'll make it better so I think
Republicans are in for a pretty
extraordinary win next week across the
board yeah and it's it's funny because
you talk about local here's what local
said uh hokel claims Republican crime
concerns our conspiracy uh Governor
hulkel claimed worries about crime ahead
of midterm election where a conspiracy
and said her opponent lizeldin and other
Republican critics were data deniers
these are Master manipulators they have
their this conspiracy going all across
America trying to convince people in the
Democratic states that they are not safe
uh well guess what they're also not only
election denies they're also data
deniers safe places are the Democratic
states you said murders were down 14 in
New York City compared to last year but
all other major crimes were up including
33 Rising robberies and police
statistics show when you hear her say
stuff like this here's what I ask myself
because she said set this on the show
yesterday
does the voter believe her and if yes
what percentage devoted that would vote
blue actually believes her saying that
what do you think the voters thinking
about so the voters don't believe her
because this is a you don't see what you
actually see liberal she's out there you
know she's a big government girl and
this has been her motto throughout by
the way for the last year and a half or
whatever it's been you don't see what's
actually happening you don't feel it
you're not really afraid to walk to the
grocery store and people are like no
actually I am so that's not going to be
a successful argument the problem in a
place like New York is that you have a
bunch of Voters and this happens in very
liberal cities oftentimes where they
will vote Democrat regardless you could
put Fidel Castro on the voting ball they
don't care it's like d oh he's Jack
that's oh yeah they won't care they will
they will to be outside yeah both sides
absolutely do that the problem is is
that when she's the problem you need
someone to what you need is a voter to
say this stuff's not working maybe I've
always been a lifelong Democrat maybe I
support the ideals of the party as they
once were this stuff is not for me
what's more important to me right now is
my Safety and Security and the Safety
and Security of my family end of story
and they have to call her Bluff so they
have to be willing to say sorry Kathy
and and by the way allow yourself to be
insulted by this because again this is
the left infantilizing you I talk about
this all the time by saying no no you're
a little baby you're a little baby and
you don't actually feel what you feel
you need to be able to respond as a
grown person I don't care liberal
Conservative Republican Democrat and say
no actually I do feel it I do feel it I
had to you know I'm afraid to go to walk
my kid to school every day and it's
because a lot of the policies coming out
of liberal DA's in New York City that
allow criminals to roam free so have a
response and feel okay with that even if
you are a lifelong Democrat and that
your commitment is to the party and the
cause something's gone wrong can she
lose
I think she can lose I I don't
if I had to guess I'd say she probably
won't lose but the fact that it's this
close the fact that it's this close in
New York state tells you what's going to
happen in other states around the
country that are not New York which are
it's going to be it's going to be a GOP
sweep but Jed let me ask you um she she
took over after Andrew Cuomo was was
given these the the left hook he's out
yeah so it's not like she had this like
sort of left
to be the governor she was sort of the
fill-in yep to replace him it wasn't
like there was this Groundswell of
people we love Kathy holcell and she got
elected she was replaced she got in
clearly things in New York have not done
well over the last few years so it's not
like there's this major base that she
has other than the traditional blue
Democrat liberal New York base so uh
anyway that I'm just pointing that out
it's not like she was elected she was
replaced
um
part number two is me at least at this
point in my life like it's very hard to
just trust what politicians say in
general left and right but especially
during election season during midterms
they're just gonna say whatever they got
to say to get elected whether it's true
whether it's not true I mean we're
living that in in midterms right now so
of course she's gonna say whatever she's
saying right now of course she's gonna
say don't believe Your Lying Eyes just
trust the trust the process here so
she's gonna do what she's got to do to
stay elected I think she will get
reelected again she's running for
governor in the one of the bluest states
in the country I think she was a couple
months ago she was up by like 20 points
I think it's narrowed to like six or
seven or eight that's still a quite
significant lead especially one week out
but we'll see we'll see if New Yorkers
are truly truly truly ready to make a
change or if they're just going to kind
of live the status quo that they've been
delivering they haven't sunk enough yet
New York City New York City in
particular which drags the whole state
down repeatedly every every year needs
to sink a little bit more for New
Yorkers to wake up and get a Giuliani
that came out of the David Dickens of
the world
um
she wasn't elected you're right but she
it has governed as a Democrat would
govern she's done nothing different from
any other standard you know hard left
Democrat in that position she's done
exactly what I would anticipate that any
Democrat would do
um and that's why yes you're right the
point you make about it's election
season right now they're going to say
whatever they need to say that's 100
valid which is why I always tell people
ignore everything that any politician
says in the couple of months before and
after like right around the election
time
um even after sometimes because then
it's a whole bunch of excuses as to why
they didn't do this look a year back at
what they actually did policy wise go
back a year when they weren't
campaigning when they weren't on the
campaign Stomp and look at what they
actually did policy wise what they were
look look back at what Kathy hokel was
saying about lockdowns remember those
beautiful pictures of Kathy that was
standing she was maskless standing in
front of a group of a whole bunch of
little kids with masks on look at what
she advocated when it came to the
lockdowns what was she saying about
mandatory experimental vaccines What
would she's saying about all these
things then you're going to know what
her position actually is because right
now she's desperate she's afraid you
think she's not looking and saying I'm
in New York state and Lee zeldin is
right on my tail come on what you're
basically saying is roll the tapes look
back a year ago 100 to see what people
say Yes um I haven't been following this
Dr Oz fetterman race he's close I know
sort of a national story because they're
it's like you take it no you take it you
take it nobody wants it no I don't think
Pennsylvania wants either them right but
if you look at fetterman and it seems
like he's not the healthiest guy he had
to get a stroke like less than six
months ago but his response one of the
clips I did see that were like you're
you're uh you've been against fracking
and he's like essentially like no I I
like Frack yeah crack me like right like
well a year ago you didn't you were
talking [ __ ] about fracking you said you
were anti-fracking he's like I Frack me
Frack that's basically that's actually a
pretty good summary of what was said too
people at home they're a lot that's
pretty close yeah so me like frackie
yeah and they they did it I I was about
to say that I saw his ad yesterday and I
was watching his ad and this is his ad
just so you know look at my eyes folks
here's his ad
in his reading
and just sitting there he's just reading
reading reading and you can tell it's
just they're telling him what to say and
he's not saying it himself it's not a
True Believer if Oz loses it'll tell you
how much influence politics has the fact
that people just want to go just one
side because prior to us running what
did the world think about us people love
Roz they followed his stuff they
respected his stuff the moment he said
he's running God forbid you run on that
side now Oz is a bad candidate like you
said they're both bad candidates you
know some word that you use Oz has never
been seen as a guy that had any issues
until he ran against this guy right now
he's this horrible person one problem
with causes the the real Oz is not a
Pennsylvania Pittsburgh guy like that's
the whole not he's like he just kind of
like transplanted there and he's like
hey Pittsburgh Philly I'm with you
they're like yeah not so much Oz didn't
I have that one most of these guys are
not most of these guys are not do you
think Biden is yeah let me tell you why
I went to school with a few Puerto
Ricans the Dominicans what are you
talking about but he's from Delaware
yeah but to say to to say I had
Dominican friends they're like you had
Dominic and then they did that did you
see the Puerto Rican haircut they made
of them or no have you seen this meme
have you seen this meme if you haven't
it's by far you have to find it just
look typing Joe Biden Puerto Rican type
in Joe Biden Puerto Rican it's the best
man no no you gotta you gotta find this
listen I I would do you the viewer an
injustice if you don't see this because
you deserve it I think you as a loyal
audience deserve to see Joe Biden with
his Puerto Rican haircut I'm excited to
actually see this oh man you telling me
you don't have this meme oh buddy it's
mandatory there you can't find it on
DuckDuckGo Tyler I mean what else oh my
God love me sometimes okay anyway so so
while you're doing this do me a favor
pull up the crime because somebody asked
the question about
top crime in America and says liberal is
it conservative okay let's find out
these cities most violent cities in
America go up go up go up go up go up go
up to the right to the ranking okay St
Louis is it the liberal or conservative
any major city any major city yeah is
gonna be blue any major city got it so
the crime in all major cities ran by
liberals is the highest crime in America
so when people say when hokel says it's
not this it's not that no problem here's
what your policies are doing it's so bad
that Nancy Pelosi's husband was broken
into his house and yesterday the I think
it's the D.A that was talking about it
saying when the man broke into his house
he was in his underwear and he got up
and went to the other place to make the
phone call and so but these are the
policies of San Francisco and the guy
that broke into San Francisco he's a BLM
guy that broke into the place of San
Francisco according to people that knew
this guy said this isn't this is a BLM
Guy this is a guy that supported BLM
this is a guy that support a lot of that
stuff but broke in but wait another guy
in the neighborhood they would say yeah
using drugs openly yeah but I thought he
was more of a q Anon Maga guy from what
I've heard though no no he had a BLM
flag on his he lived in a bus he had a
BLM flag an lgbtq flag a bus parked in
the front yard of a deterioration it's
like a hippie commune
uh took uh but that was the media story
that you're citing the media story
initially was oh this is a republican q
and on guy and then they dug and we're
like uh not exactly and he wound up
being this hippie commune drug user guy
a troubled guy mental health issues but
but more than anything the the stories
that I've heard again we're going to go
with we can't trust what the media is
saying left right we're just hearing
stories the story that I'm hearing
putting out there especially on the
right is like this was his gay lover
entanglement issue male prostitute about
that which is nothing but the truth I'm
not on that well people are approaching
that is my point you know what rational
neighbors were saying this is a troubled
guy that's using drugs to get this bus
parked over in the lawn they got all
these signs up he's you know yelling at
the moon and he's just a really troubled
guy I think that has been fully
established the guy with mental health
issues somehow ended up inside Paul
Pelosi's house and bonked him with a
hammer right so looking for Nancy though
well he wasn't coming there who knows
how do you know that though that's the
party
this is the part again the first thing
they did the first thing they did is
blame who Republicans the first thing
they did is blame Republicans the first
thing they did
blame all the war blame queuing on he's
part the first thing and then a day
later oh he's he's gay he's a prostate
he's he's a new he's a PLM he's a LGBT
oh well no no let's let's move on with
the story okay so here's what's going on
over here in Chicago so so like Jesse's
that's the that's the part where they
the reason why a New York could almost
lose governorship is because people are
saying I am not dumb you know the The
Joe Rogan said something yesterday he
says the the red uh uh the what did he
call it is it's gonna be like The
Shining when the elevator opens you know
the the the way people are going to be
voting red he says like when the
elevator opens from shining he says it's
gonna be insane what's gonna happen on
that side and obviously we're gonna find
that next week how much of this is just
gibberish and how much of this is
credibility or not you know people
aren't dumb and I think one of the
things I was looking at is you step back
from the election season and you look
what happened to the D.A Adam the D.A of
San Francisco right those people had a
had a referendum against the D.A in San
Francisco why was that they weren't in
the middle of election season with
million dollar ads and billboards and TV
and radio that you can't avoid right
they were I see needles I see human
feces I see homeless encampments I see
my city deteriorating I see somebody
mugs me and they're back out on the
street two weeks later on the same
Corner waiting to mug me again time out
I'm done with it and to your point Pat
the San Francisco voters were not dumb
did they stop being liberal stop having
certain views no they didn't but they
looked around and they said you as my
D.A are not keeping my city with I want
the liberal values to be here but it's
got to be safe at a basic level and I
see this and I'm not done so guess what
you're done and that's what they did you
probably got the story somewhere on the
liberal uh the recall let's not forget
that they invalidated half a million
votes
um and they cheated these people out of
recalling uh gascon uh no I'm just
looking at the D.A and I'm looking at
things that they really saw in San
Francisco you know what people really
saw they tried and then uh they
invalidated half a million signatures
out of the 715 000. so during the
presidential election or the
gubernatorial election for Gavin Newsom
everybody can vote everybody in their
freaking mother can vote and they're not
going to recall a single ballot I'm not
talking Governor I was just talking to
San Francisco D.A but that's what I'm
saying when they're trying to do a
recall and they're trying to pull George
gascon out they're going to recall half
a million ballots like it just shows how
everything's Twisted that's the Lida you
go to San Francisco D.A and that guy got
tossed out on his head when you're what
you're talking about though Tom when you
say liberal values oftentimes in these
places like the New York cities the San
Francisco's what they want upheld is
like the the social values like for
example Giuliani got elected Giuliani
was pro-choice it would be impossible
impossible for a pro-life candidate to
win in New York
um I don't know about what where Lee
zeldon stands on the pro-life issue or
how I've spoken he is about that but
oftentimes they're talking about like
where do you stand on abortion where do
you stand on this but they prioritize
these liberal voters do prioritize
Safety and Security they may back the
defund the police movement with a
sticker in their window but they don't
want to be unsafe they want to know that
when they pick up the phone and they
call for the police that the police show
up and they want to know that they get
there in time so this perception is oh
liberals don't care about safety no
liberals don't care liberals want the
slogan they want to be in the cool Club
defund the police BLM put the flags up
all that stuff but they don't want that
lack of safety to impact their
neighborhood or their family once they
does once it actually lands in their
backyard they will absolutely Embrace
somebody who prioritizes their security
as long as that person also bows to some
key issues has to be you know
pro-abortion has to be you know there's
certain boxes that need to be checked by
liberals that they just cannot all
lifestyles are valid our article came
out from Washington examiners saying
only 17 of black voters support
defunding the police the survey of black
voters conducted by the grion kff
published on Wednesday as thousand black
adults who say they are registered to
vote for their opinion on policing about
half of those polled 48 percent said
they would like to see police funding
kept about the same while 34 percent
said they wanted increased financial
support just 17 percent responded that
they support decreasing the funding for
the police the poll also found out that
three and four black voters viewed
criminal justice and policing as a very
important factor in making their
decision about who to vote for including
77 percent of Democrats and 68 percent
of Republicans the issue of crime was as
important for those who made under 40
000 per year as for those making over
ninety thousand dollars more important
interesting should be more important
under 40 than above because people the
community you're living in well yeah the
community you're living in The Police
become more valuable a lot of people who
make more money have access to private
security and all those perks but if
you're making forty thousand dollars a
year and and particularly by the way if
you live in an area where your Second
Amendment right isn't protected these
people aren't armed themselves these
law-abiding citizens so they rely
heavily on the police being active and
present and they don't have the money to
afford the private security that's some
of the issues that came up with the Paul
Pelosi story that I think you know
everyone ran with those arguments you
said by the way the they that ran with
the arguments about its q and on this
Hillary Clinton was on board name
profiles people were just asking like
hey where are the security cameras isn't
it odd that was there an alarm system
isn't it like some of the the stuff just
wasn't making sense and they were
questioning and of course you're not
allowed to question a narrative
sometimes you know the left will jump
back and say oh well you just you want
you want violence no no one wants
violence but some of the stuff just
didn't make sense and didn't add up with
that initial narrative that Adam was
mentioning about Q Anonymous you know
it's funny uh matter you know like the
story you're telling about like how
liberals in New York will put up a
sticker let's say yeah but like that's
not the reality that they'd actually
what they stand for in real life like
have you you know this reminds me of
it's like almost like the the cognitive
dissonance of like in in real life real
time Tyler see if you can pull this up
you ever seen this I think it was like
someone sitting in an airport on their
Apple laptop computer and with like a
sticker that's like capitalism sucks all
right socialism rules while they're
sitting there on their Apple laptop with
their Apple ear uh head uh ear drums or
ear Beats or whatever
okay with their Starbucks in their hand
with their McDonald's Egg McMuffin like
capitalism sucks it's like how unaware
of you of what you have going on in your
life to be preaching that but like
living something completely different
from what you're saying on your sticker
but you know where that comes from that
comes from Academia because these kids
learn in school they have a total
disconnect like you you go through
economics you go through all these
classes and you have no concept of what
these policies actually look like in the
real world so they're dissociated from
reality and it's like oh I'm gonna sit
here and oh wait a minute is this
something that emerged from capitalism
there's no thought process there so
they're just like the talking points the
sticker being accepted but they don't
actually process that what they're
advocating for would prevent them from
living the lifestyle that they actually
want to live well it's it's Martha's
Vineyard yeah how fast did they bring in
the National Guard two days for two it
was a couple hundred migrants right two
days they brought in the National Guard
kicked those people out the same people
that have black lives matter nobody
we're all immigrants nobody's illegal
Etc et cetera et cetera this has been
going on for 30 years or more right this
is the whole limousine liberal movement
right and I I separate that from I think
what really happened which was an
absolute
um not to be ironic but a crime what
happened is the people that are in the
inner cities in those areas living down
there trying to find a better job trying
to escape trying to get to the next rung
of a social ladder
you have to see what happened in a lot
of these cities to avoid engagements the
police reduced patrols from like 11 pm
to 6 a.m and so the people that were
living down there that were not drug
dealers they were living in
neighborhoods they could afford living
in neighborhoods they'd live for
generations and just trying to find
where do I go from here what's my next
step where's the jobs where's
the thing and they're down there and
they're the victims of the crimes and
they're the victims of what's going on
down there and then the police defunded
or intimidated to the point that they
with the body cams and everything they
don't want engagements they don't want
to go down there and Patrol because it's
going to create an engagement it's going
to create an engagement on film and the
films can be used in a narrative and so
the people that really lose here he says
and that it should be not surprising to
anybody to say that 17 of American
African-American or black voters
support defunding the police and the 83
percent of them are uh no I I need the
police and I need them to be down here
um and I think there's some cities like
Dallas that have shown you know
exemplary change and then you've got
places right now where would you have
ever thought Pat that the political
polling in Oregon would be what it is
right now instead of an election strange
why is that did maybe crime and economy
ever hit people so first thing if you
ever build a country and you're
competing say the war you know
Armageddon happens there's only a
million people left everyone's thinking
about where to put their kids and where
to raise their family the first thing a
mom thinks about is the s word it's
security and safety if you can't provide
that in any City in any state in any
country you lose people period mom's
going to sit there and say listen man I
have one job the Natural Instinct of a
mom is to protect their kids you screw
with her you you have a Wrong Enemy you
cannot mess with moms and that's what
they do it's just not gonna work out all
right so let's talk about Kanye because
I know you got some thoughts on Kanye
I'm gonna read both stories adamant and
you can comment on it I'll go first with
his comments about George Floyd and then
we'll go into what 50 Cent said uh uh so
I think that's on page
uh six or seven is it six okay six oh
here we go so Connie West apologizes for
spreading Lies by George Floyd's that
this is uh Kanye offered what the media
is calling an apology for comments he
made in reference to George Floyd if we
call West uh recently declared that
Floyd died from Fentanyl and now due to
homicide under the knee of the Derek
chovin when I see that video as a black
person it hurts my feelings and I know
that police do attack and what America
is generally and that America is
generally racist and I understand that
when we got to say black lives matter
the idea of it made us feel good
together as people now afterwards there
were uh there were some things where the
money went in order to push us to uh the
Democratic vote so when I questioned The
Death of George Floyd it hurt my people
I want to apologize because God has
showed me by what Adidas is doing by
what the media is doing I know what it
feels to have a knee on my neck right
now so and then 50 Cent came out and
said Kanye should Master the art of
shutting the up okay that's what he said
I've seen people in this position
because of uh things they have done not
things they have said now you gotta
Master the art of shutting the hell up
the rapper was reportedly reacting to
CNN Headline alleging West has a
disturbing history of admiring
Hitler I have never seen anything like
this before a screenshot I think Kanye
should buy the car he likes the best and
just ride off into the sunset it's
really a wrap people are really hurt by
this [ __ ] us and there's a bunch of
other things that came after that black
people are actually uh anyways these are
the comments he made about Jews and
blacks and comparing them so Adam
thoughts on the story look I haven't
really been
obviously I've been following Kanye well
for you obviously decades now but
obviously over the last few weeks I
haven't really been
too opinionated because I was more
asking questions than making statements
something that I think we could all kind
of get behind like before you start oh I
believe this I say this like let's hear
let's hear him out and see what he has
to say with that being said I've really
had an opportunity to kind of process
what's going on with Kanye and then to a
bigger context like the groups or the
people that he's really hurting so
number one
um
Kanye is a musical genius I'm I like I'm
okay with saying that like he's created
Amazing Music he's he's he's a
Trailblazer he's awesome in that regard
but the problem with Geniuses sometimes
is they even as great as they are in
their respective careers they have blind
spots okay so Kanye what are some of his
blind spots clearly he's a narcissist
clearly he has a God complex he doesn't
know how to just be a normal guy why
would he he's been pedestaled and
elevated and coddled everywhere he's
gone over the last 10 20 years because
of the greatness that he's reached so if
you have these blind spots you don't
know how to treat people you don't know
how to interact with people you're not a
man of the people you're doing things
for the attention of your brand Okay so
you can be a genius but also have major
issues in your situation but a lot of
what
people aren't really addressing about
Kanye and I've said this before and I'll
say it again is the influence that the
Kardashian female matriarchy has had on
this man's life I've said this before
again we all know my history with the
Kardashians my best friend Kris
Humphries married Kim 2011. I live the
Kardashian life for a [ __ ] year I saw
this lifestyle I saw this bubble and I
saw the head of the matriarchy Kris
Jenner and her influence over all the
women in this family but let's look at
what's happened to all the men in this
family and that's what people are not
addressing with Kanye like all right
we'll start with Bruce Jenner this was a
like world famous Olympian decathlon uh
goat and now he's a transgender woman
okay cool the father dead how did he die
like at a young age I don't know I'm not
that's not a conspiracy I'm just saying
he's died at a young age if you go down
the list Lamar Odom turned in from an
NBA athlete to a literal crackhead okay
Scott Disick who is a good looking young
guy would ever rehab Galore and I'm
friends with him so I'm not talking [ __ ]
if you when you look at
um the other men in the family Rob
Kardashian is a recluse hasn't been seen
in years the women run the show in that
family so when you bring in a leader
like Kanye a man like a man who like has
conviction and you kind of feminize him
and say we run the show now and he
already has mental health issues and
bipolar Tendencies like how do you
expect him to react and then final point
to the Kim K thing is
dude he's been completely
demasculated with this whole Pete
Davidson situation where you're going to
leave your husband Kim K and start
parading with this [ __ ] joke of a guy
Pete Davidson what do you think that's
going to do to someone who has a fragile
ego and a fragile mental capacity
already despite his you know amazing
gifts like that's gonna [ __ ] you up so
what he's doing and what he's feeling
there's so much going on that it's hard
to kind of put your self in Kanye's
shoes because you don't know like when
you're operating at such a high level
even Rogan said like when you plug in
you see what he said about like a
hundred electricity vaults and and
that's something that's only has a 40
watt capacity there's so much going on
that how can you restrain that with that
being said that doesn't excuse what he's
been saying specifically about Jews now
any time that you paint a group whether
it's blacks gays Jews Asians this and
you start group talking rather than
individuals that's going to be a problem
and as a Jew initially I didn't
overreact we've had multiple shows about
Kanye I haven't gone off like the wire
but here's what I've learned about Jews
especially talking with friends and
especially being around Miami Beach and
seeing what's going on Jews are not
[ __ ] playing anymore
all right we're not [ __ ] playing
everything that's happened in Jewish
history
culminating with the Holocaust which
eventually led to the creation of the
state of Israel in 1948 there's been a
run-up of Jews being the scapegoat and
being the bad guy and being the person
or the group of people that were the the
reasons why societies have not thrived
and were declining and it ended with the
final solution that Hitler tried to
accomplish murdering six million Jews
and at some point Jews were like that's
it and there's a saying in Judaism never
again
so when there's even like a a small blip
on the radar of people painting Jews to
be whatever as he grounds well within
Jews we're like that ain't [ __ ]
happening and like if you look at the
creation of Israel and what they've been
able to do over the last 50 60 years and
become the great powerful Nation where
you're you're the size of [ __ ]
Delaware amongst a sea of Arab people
that have always wanted your death and
you see what Israel has turned into in
the IDF and Mossad and what that's
turned into it's Jews are just not going
to accept this anymore so by default
there's going to be a defensive reaction
and also an offensive reaction by Jews
to say listen Kanye shut the [ __ ] up
we're not playing like that we're not
playing this game you've tried to murder
every single one of our people we're not
even allowing this to happen and then
for I'll give you one final case example
for like the people out there that are
like well the Jews they're all in
cahoots and they run the world it's like
well let's like look here politically in
America two of the biggest fundraisers
for in politics on the those are Jews on
the left you can point to George Soros
he has a very specific agenda whether
you agree with it or disagree with it we
know that he has an agenda and on the
right side of things
uh rest in peace with Sheldon Adelson
hardcore Republican hardcore
conservative Heart Like
multi-multi-multi millions and billions
of dollars that they've both put into
the system now if Jews are in cahoots to
run the world why would two famous
Jewish billionaires be completely
funding complete opposite agendas like
give me an answer to that so anyway
that's my thoughts on Kanye and anytime
you label a group you're going to have
an issue especially these days as the
Jews I love two of the things you talk
first of all the anti-semitic stuff he
says is just bad I mean people should
just be able to look at that and just
say all right this is just bad and I
think you have seen a lot of people
rally you know with the Jewish Community
who are tired of the way anti-Semitism
has been tolerated by many for a very
long time are saying enough Kanye listen
I oftentimes listen to him and I have to
be honest I don't understand a lick of
what he's saying I don't understand a
lot of what he's saying I I almost feel
like this guy is trying to figure out
how he feels about stuff out loud and he
should just take a minute to just maybe
he's not used to being in the Limelight
maybe he's not in terms of talking about
his opinions you know he's getting
invited on Fox news shows this is new
for him this is different it's different
it's one thing to be an artist and to
have an opinion it's another thing you
know to be front and center in these
types of interviews I think he needs to
sit back and he needs to think a little
bit about how he feels about stuff about
what he might be asked about what he's
comfortable putting out there it seems
to me now that this stuff about George
Floyd he's walking this back saying you
know well I needed to clarify I need
well that involves thinking about how
you really feel about issues and
understanding that once you put it out
there it's very hard to say oh no
actually what I really meant is this so
even though he's famous he's front and
center for his you know artistic work
and all of that he hasn't been famous in
this way you know you know looking to
become the CEO of parlor and getting
highly political when it comes to his
content and when you get highly
political every time you know I always
say every time I open my mouth half the
country's Gonna Hate what I say but a
lot of it is very well thought out
beforehand you know I want to make sure
I'm comfortable with what I'm saying if
I'm comfortable with what I'm saying
cool half the country can hate what I'm
saying but I don't know that he's always
comfortable with the message he's
putting out there then there seems to be
a some reflection and then he kind of
changes it so he just needs to
understand he's in new Turf right now
and he's going to be held accountable
for the things he says when it comes to
politics when it comes to comments like
this so This anti-semitic stuff rubs a
lot of people wrong rightfully so I love
that angle you took with the Kardashians
the Kardashian culture is incredibly
toxic I mean that is you want to talk
about we we talk about toxic masculinity
that's actually toxic femininity that's
the face of it her face that whole
family it's a it's a hot mess so I don't
know I'm not going to blame the
Kardashians for what's happening to
Kanye in any way because I think he had
some troubled stuff going on with
himself before but I don't see how any
strong opinionated man survives that
place I don't I don't think it's
possible I mean I think that's why you
see the Pete Davidsons I mean these are
all just that's not I don't even know
that that's real but I don't think it
helped him to be in that culture you're
a strong opinionated guy who's going to
see the world differently potentially
than them you're not going to survive
that you're going to come out there
frustrated antagonized so I don't think
it helped to I think it caused some of
what we're seeing now in terms of his
kind no but I certainly don't think it
helped him to be to be on the more
stable side of issues um I just think he
needs to think like he needs to reflect
he needs to because you need to own what
you say you know and people need to
apologize if he doesn't feel that way he
should apologize if he does feel that
way he should own it and you know
consequences come when they come and if
companies don't want to associate with
him or whatnot he's going to have to
deal with that consequence but I find
him an incredibly odd figure when I list
him I find myself trying to decipher
what what and oftentimes I'm lost in a
cave I'm like what what is he saying
what's going on and I don't know if
that's uh people say oh it's mental hell
I don't know what it is is it just a guy
who's new to this component and trying
to figure out where he stands on stuff
out loud I don't know I really don't
quick response just on the Kardashian
thing
um just to kind of give you a a case
example
Connie has been very explicit he has
major problems with uh he I don't know
what he calls her exactly but uh Kris
Jenner like comment on Chris or general
Chris they kind of has like a little
funny word for her basically she's the
dictator right and the problem that
happened with my friend what he's a good
guy from is from the Minneapolis
Midwestern values when he got into the
family married they're like all right
this is the way we do things around her
this is the way we're going to operate
he's like yeah I don't I don't want to
do that and like to the point where he's
like yeah like you're gonna move to
Minneapolis and be a part of like she's
like are you [ __ ] kid I'm staying in
L.A like we're doing LA and that was
part they're like hey you should
probably have that conversation before
he got married but that was the
Whirlwind situation that that was but
here's a guy with like actual principles
and Midwestern good values that got you
know
infiltrated into this La Hollywood
toxic feminism scene that you're talking
about and it just obviously wouldn't
work but Kanye was been in that for 10
years like what kind of stuff do you
think that's happened to his mentality
since that so I think that I think even
if you're in it though like the
Kardashian Clan and what they do and
what they're capable of and all the
women and it's like there's something
odd even if you're in the entertainment
culture and in the entertainment
business I think there's something
deeply odd about the way they build
their their empire and the stuff that
they do and I I just I don't understand
why any Midwestern guy truthfully I
don't successful I don't I don't know
what the draw is there I mean I really
don't there's a whole lot of fake going
on anyone who markets themselves by the
way I always tell people as just pure
fake top to bottom there's a lot of
stuff going on behind the scenes
probably that you're not gonna like but
yeah I think that I think I believe that
I believe that you walk into that as a
guy and it's just like sit down shut up
we're gonna tell you how it's gonna go
that would certainly not work for a
Kanye which is why I would wonder why
you would even go there that's certainly
not going to work for any guy who wants
some autonomy over his own life and his
own media presence and his own I mean
it's like you walk in there and it's
like is it a contract do you sign a form
that you give your life away wouldn't
surprise me
um for the gift of being with a cartoon
is it fair to to ask like you you have
zero interest in Kim even though she's
single
Kim you have my number I'm sorry
wouldn't that be the plots but do you
think that actually like remove the Jed
you know hat and just put yourself in a
typical yeah Woman these days
like do you actually think that women
think that the Kardashians and the
genders all that are actually toxic for
women or are they actually more of a uh
you know like a hero or like someone you
look at as like I want to be like them
more put on a pedestal like as a woman
not Jed how do you think women it's hard
for me to remember exactly but I think
it's split I think there's people who
look at them as females and feel like
they're destroying culture like women
are saying you know they're fake they're
phony you know you have tons of girls
throughout the country that are going
into doctor's office and saying give me
the Kardashian face I mean they're
marketing themselves as real they're not
I mean just look at the look just look
at the images of them and the
progression they're not owning the
reality of what they're even living so I
think there's a segment of the female
population that knows that this is bad
for future generations of girls that
know that Kim Kardashian became famous
from a sex tape that many have come out
now and and speculated and and some have
attested alleged that it was organized
by you know her mom so you know there's
a lot of darkness and weirdness about it
and then I think there are the cult
following like young girls that just see
a bunch of women and they're like
they're famous and they're curious and
they're like oh if I do this will I be
famous this is how you get followers
look at Kylie Jenner Kylie Jenner is
famous because she completely altered
her appearance and she became I mean
another version of Kim Kardashian she
kind of looks like this odd version of
her sister I don't know that she would
be famous had she not done that in fact
I know that she wouldn't is she
successful has she built a billion
dollar business is she sure great you
know I'm not taking that away from her
but a lot of their Fame is attributed to
a sex tape and a lot of this physical
Distortion that's happened so do I think
there are a lot of moms out there and
women out there that have a problem with
that and don't want their young girls
modeling themselves off the Kardashians
absolutely you know what's crazy the
craziest thing because I went over all
the guys in the family that have had
major issues or whatever I didn't talk
about Tristan Thompson the NBA player
he's kind of been cheating allegations
with Chloe and all that nonsense but you
know his name I don't hear a lot about
and people kind of forget that Travis
Scott one of the biggest rappers alive
right now like is brother-in-law's with
Kanye like he's in that family yeah you
very rarely hear anything about him and
his involvement in that family does he
play along maybe he plays I don't know
that's my point is like he has his rap
career obviously we know what happened
with him at the that Festival where a
handful of people were killed and but
like as far as Kardashian and it like
issues you don't hear a lot about that
we'll see what happens with Travis Scott
because he hasn't been in the news in
that regard so let's see my last
question 30 seconds will Kanye make a
comeback or is this a downfall that's
going to be hard to recover from that's
going to take a few years to come back
I'll be very clear unless his music
lives up to the standards that he's
already put out there I do not think so
because people aren't trying to hear
Kanye for his political views or his
business ideas you know there's a famous
saying I miss the old Kanye I miss the
people actually missed the old Kanye
because of his music not because of his
ideology so no I don't think there will
be a comeback unless the music do you
think you think he's done done
what do you think oh I think he really
showed his true colors I mean I think
this I said the gesture I think this is
absolute cowardice he said stupid [ __ ]
for 10 years he's gotten backlash for
since Trump ran he wore the freaking
Mega hat and now all of a sudden he
loses to 2 billion he loses his
endorsements Etc et cetera et cetera now
it's oh my God I'm so sorry Merrick is
racist uh George Floyd died from a knee
on the neck um you know just begging for
forgiveness for his two million or two
billion back and granted I've never lost
2 billion in a day but no I I think he
showed his true colors and I don't think
he makes a comeback that's it you think
it's done I think I think well I I think
he showed his fans like the people that
follow him now not for music but outside
that I think he showed it exactly Kevin
Spacey ever comes back
and becomes Kevin Spacey without us
looking at him the way we looked at him
I think so but I think it's two
different things music is inherently fad
based right and trend-based whereas an
actor and actress can come back as an as
an older version of themselves
particularly males yeah not not females
as much because once you're 40 in
Hollywood don't attack me here you're
80. I'm not gonna attack no seriously
once you're 40 is a female you're 80.
but can Kevin Spacey come back I mean
look at what I like to look at Michael
Keaton he didn't have like a crisis but
let's just take a look he had this lull
where his career was gone and all of a
sudden he's he came back and there was
things in his career well look that's
the way Hollywood works because acting
is different than music music is fad
based I think it's really hard for uh
Kanye to come back what do you think
about it you know for me here's here's
what we're learning who you can call out
and who you cannot call out like there
there is there are certain people in the
room you can insult and certain people
cannot insult uh you're you're really
seeing who is one of the most powerful
communities in America that if you even
get close to insulting or touching what
the consequences could be and he's
feeling it right now especially the way
he that he did it because you can you
can insult whites as much as you want
you're not going to get in trouble
that's just the truth of it you can
people say stuff about the white
community and they butcher them around
and trash them and say whatever they
want pretty much you can pretty much say
everything you want no one says anything
God forbid
you say certain things about certain
communities oh
you're permanently done what he's saying
is not you know people have said it on
the opposite side I can if I really
wanted to do a case study I can go on
the opposite side and see how many
people have said stuff about you know uh
oh you you have to be careful saying
stuff about Muslims but you can say
whatever you want about Christians you
have to be careful about what you say
about blacks but you can say whatever
you want about white you have to be
careful saying whatever you want about
Jews but you can say whatever this is
this is also a slippery slope for me now
obviously what he said and the way he
said it death con what do you say death
content what are you doing but but a lot
of it for me comes from a standpoint of
oh my gosh who is really running this
country to protect those few that we
cannot touch that that's the one part
that that becomes a bit of a slippery
slope on uh who you can call out and who
you cannot call out and we we just
learned it this this is known as one of
the greatest artists few things that I
don't like about what he does like
posting text messages you get from
people on your Instagram back to back to
back to back to back to back to back
that's a character flaw can't do that
what are you doing posting text messages
you're getting from people on yours you
go to his Instagram profile it's all
text why are you doing that do you know
that's permanent
do you know what I'm saying when I say
that permanent if you delete it yeah
that's permanent like shot that yeah
that's Evan permanent like permanently
you're not going to be texted by people
you have to can't even go on Signal like
it's you there's certain behavior that
to me is not has nothing to do with this
to me it has to do with a complete
different thing that is um challenges
you go through you got to be very who's
what what real qualified one like a the
kind of wife that he wants who's going
to want to be with a guy like him today
knowing that at any point he can put
your business on blast publicly and by
the way the same goes with the
Kardashians what guy a real real not not
if you want to marry a celebrity because
you have to stay within the celebrity
world I get it like who's Kim gonna date
next and marry let's face it there's
odds out there for this by the way yeah
yeah so I I saw that you know Vance is
uh what's his name Vance Jones
some reason is the top of the list yeah
but but the point being who's she gonna
end up with she can only be with a power
player she's not going to end up with it
like a Pete Davidson's like yeah okay
good you had fun six months you really
messed with you know uh mess with Kanye
who did Pete date that the ex killed
himself or committed suicide Mac Miller
Mac Miller right so yeah so the pizza's
also a dark character he's also guys
Ariana Grande with Mac Miller yeah yeah
I'm sorry Ariana Grande I'm not I'm not
a follower she was engaged to Pete
Davidson that's where yeah so Stars so I
mean look there's a lot of people
involved in a situation like this but to
me it's more about character than who
you have to go back like hey J.Lo you
your brand was very good when you were
Ben Affleck those are the conversations
in this world so are you really gonna be
with somebody that you're laying next to
in bed wanting to have a conversation
how was your day or is it really did you
see my Q score went up after we got
married three months ago what a [ __ ]
conversation to have a night laying next
to a person but that's the reality but
the point is what a waste of a life what
a waste of a life what a waste of a life
favorite parts of my life or
conversations relationships moments
experiences that are re real raw genuine
moments you're going through troubles we
sit down we have a conversation you're
in tears you're opening up I'm talking
to you this is between us that's a bond
right you're going through a challenge
no one knows about it we're sharing that
that's life this this is [ __ ] this
is just
and I hope people watching this younger
Generations not sitting there saying man
I really want to be in this kind of mess
it's a completely different life anyway
so that's my opinions I just think
certain people have little too much
power today you can't talk about them it
scares the crap out back to your initial
question do you think Kanye
makes a comeback I think he does I think
he does but I think it's going to take
four to five years I think it's going to
take a while I think it's gonna take a
while this is America you have to
realize one thing about America
is very annoying with stars and they
want to see them fall they want to see
them fall but but they love Redemption
and comebacks this is America man this
is America you know like the whole
concept of the church what's the church
if you're like a born-again type of
thing if you're born again all your sins
are forgiven America if it was a
religion it's a similar feeling because
we will judge you all the way to the end
but man when you fall
you're later two years later we can't
wait for you to come back and a changed
human being hopefully and you got new
thing that we can learn from you and
redeem yourself hopefully I don't know
if it's going to happen problem though
Pat I think is that he made everybody
mad like so he made the people initially
he made the comments and he made a whole
bunch of people mad yeah he's
anti-semitic he's that then he
apologizes and now he makes a whole
bunch of other people mad that's what
they're saying oh why are you capable
but that's character right that's a
character flaw when you do that that you
said something earlier you said every
time I open my mouth I offend half so
what he did is he opened his mouth and
he opened his mouth right yeah right so
he offended 100 what are you doing bro
take a position at least at least I
respect AOC because she takes a position
you took a position go for it so now
when you're flip-flopping right John
Kerry lost the election years ago
because he flip-flopped two audiences
gave two different messages America
doesn't like flip-floppers one more
thing with Kanye I agree whether it's
the politics whether it's your your
brand your personality you have to have
a base we all know this you gotta play
to your base your base your base so
who's Kanye's base who does he actually
care about obviously he cares a lot
about his people black people like he
says this oh I got to take care of my
people I gotta help my people is there
anything that his people are not down
with more than Mega
okay like straight up just look at the
like black people don't feel Maga I
actually I disagree for 90 that's great
um but his black people aren't feeling
Mago disagree or not I'm letting you
know that ain't that's the case secondly
when you go White lives matter you think
black people are down with that I'm
saying as a group no so he's he's doing
things and then black people I think for
the most part agree that George Floyd
may have had uh fentanyl in his system
but he died because someone an officer's
in me was on the back of their neck
there's not a lot of harder guys in the
hip-hop world than Kevin Gates have you
heard what he said or Ice Cube remember
what Ice Cube said yeah you have to go
go with Kevin Gates though go with Kevin
Gates first of all I love Kevin Gates
and you know some of the stuff that he
says just like
the benefit of being a street guy and an
artist where you've partied with all
these guys and then you're like wait you
the only pieces the only people who give
me a hard time with my success is my own
people he says I've never had a white
person that's unhappy for My Success so
that conversation is being had and it
needs to be had you know for long I can
bring up a lot of different things that
has to do with this and every Community
every Community has areas to improve in
every community so so that that part is
all that I thought that part he made a
lot of progress in but he just messed it
up when he went to where he was at here
this Kevin Gates if you've not seen this
we can't play it you got to go watch
what Kevin Gates says here it's
fantastic and and I think more people
like him needs to be out there talking
himself Cube uh and when Kanye was
making some points but anyways we can we
can get away from this top because we
got a few other topics before we bring
to find out what the hell is going on in
uh with this oil situation and list
trust so Elon Musk
let's talk about musk A lot's going on
with musk um he's been trolling trolls
and he's bullying the bully and people
are losing their minds Tom and I were
talking about you said something
yesterday Tom about Canada right where
you know a lot of people that say I'm
going to leave America we're going to go
to Canada if Trump gets elected oh I'm
Gonna Leave Twitter and I'm gonna go
somewhere else if musk buys Twitter well
guess what I asked the question
yesterday I said what is the Canada for
Twitter for people that want to leave
Twitter there is a liberal social media
site called tribal have you heard about
tribal yes have you guys heard about
tribal or no so I I actually went and
look them up and their mission statement
if you go on their Twitter account go to
Twitter put a tribal Twitter profile and
and and and their mission statement is
actually very interesting I hope they
pinned it to the top that's not the one
it's another one uh anyways I think it's
called tribal social or something like
that and they said what we do is
um tribal
um so streaming music service called
tribal right title you're talking about
titles called t-i-d-a-l title yeah yeah
anyways there was something out there
that we saw this but let me let me just
read this with musk let me just read
this with musk I'll look it up here in a
minute
uh verify Twitter users May soon have to
pay monthly fee to keep their badge
under musk's leadership okay this is a
story that just came out
uh Twitter Executives spend the weekend
discussing a possible
um uh uh change to social media platform
where users have to pay subscribe to the
blue badges Twitter blue right now it's
4.99. it's actually a great service by
the way it launched last year's
platforms premium offering giving users
access to new features like customizable
app icons the ability to undo or
bookmark tweets and a reader mode or
more easily view long threads of posts a
verification to your subscription May
cost 19.99 a month The Verge reported
should Twitter require payments for its
verified status it would be the first
major American social media app to do so
as most platforms offer the feature for
free so what do you think about this 20
a month concept Tom here's what I think
about it Elon Musk is knows how to make
money and he knows what he's doing here
and what people don't know and I spoke
to two people yesterday and I said
um let me ask you a question do you pay
the 34.99 on LinkedIn well yeah I do why
well because you get the profile I get
all the and all of a sudden they stopped
they're like oh so in other words
LinkedIn free
you'd only get you so far but if you pay
the 34.99 you get all the other benefits
and the power users
HR people recruiters they have to pay
the big fees so that they can have more
than 500 outreaches per month on
LinkedIn all that Elon Musk is doing is
bringing Commerce elements to Twitter
that are indeed valuable that if you
want them you pay for them and I think
it's taking a page right out of uh the
most profitable social network and
history LinkedIn and Reed Hoffman that's
what I think is going on and it's a
little more charged and a little bit
more exciting and a little bit more
debated right now but that's all he's
doing that's all he's doing he's
following the LinkedIn model that's
right you actually think he's uh
following someone else's model the Jeff
Bezos Amazon Prime model he sees what
his boy Bezos is doing who wouldn't have
Amazon Prime to free delivery and all
that you're signing up for that
especially if you've got some money like
of course I'll do this so he's not an
idiot he knows how to make money he sees
what linkedin's doing what Amazon's
doing he's going to charge for premium
where where does service where does Reed
read come from the PayPal Mafia right
correct right I think you're making the
same point with the different uh
entrepreneur but it's the same point
it's like you know what let's go make
some money on this this can't just be
eyeballs from here to Mars and back
right because eyeballs doesn't make me
money and so I think what he's done here
it's a lightning rod for controversy but
he's just looking at it and saying
everybody else pays for something
valuable on the platform whether it's
Amazon Prime or or basic LinkedIn damn
it they're going to pay that here do you
think it incentivizes the the concept of
like then everyone's gonna have a
verified badge like everyone just
because they're going to view it as a
money making opportunity so it's going
to basically be everywhere as opposed to
so is that is it just like meaningless
then at that point I agree I think it
all depends is it curated it's like you
have to go like if you want to get a
insurance license you have to take a
test but then you have the license it's
either going to be some level of
curation there right like I'm gonna say
look all right I validated your presence
whatever it is you know social media
influencer media personnel reality
politician all those categories a
business executive that's noteworthy
okay so we validated you you passed the
test would you like to pay twenty
dollars for the blue check
I I hope they keep doing it that way so
that it's curated credibility okay so
let me take let me take a couple things
here I think what he's doing is genius I
somebody asked me a question what would
you do about this I said if I could get
in right now and invest five 10 million
bucks I'm in it right now I would invest
into Twitter I said it before this
thing's going to be a trillion dollar
app and I'm saying it again I believe
it's going to be a trillion dollar
company because this guy knows how to
make money and the things he's making
are not dumb he asked a question the
other day what should we do to increase
the value of tick tock to increase the
value of uh what do you call it uh
Twitter people started responding one of
the first people that responded was Mr
Beast and Mr B says whatever you do
don't do something that's easily
duplicatable and copied because other
people will do it okay other people will
do Mr B's advice fantastic advice then
others said bring back Vine so he did a
poll talking about should I bring back
Vine
5 million people voted okay 70 percent
of people said bring back Vine seventy
percent said bring you back 30 said
don't bring you back and the part about
doing the verified stuff that they're
paying 20 bucks a month you know what I
like about the 20 a month concept Tom
here's what I like about it I like the
fact that now
all of those gaslighting fake Twitter
profiles that made us think somebody's a
bad person or not gone so guess what
well you know watch what all these
people are saying on the Twitter they're
defending this or they're against this
really how many of them are blue check
marks so you can go buy it if you're a
real account go pay 20 bucks a month
well you know no it's just now we know
what Bots are so I get so many bot
comments on Instagram this person
changed my life because of the crypto
course I took I don't even know how to
eliminate these guys right well you know
which ones I'm talking about they come
out of nowhere and by the way even on
YouTube our Clips we put do you know
invite Timmy you see those clips on the
bottom it says with the valuetainment
logo or PVD podcast logo and they say
DM me for advice on business with
Bitcoin every time I block him Google
doesn't block all of them they just
block that one comment correct they
don't block the user so if musk can get
rid of bots if musk can get rid of the
[ __ ] if musking get rid of all these
gamification that's taking place I think
this app is supposed to be a very very
powerful app and for those who don't
like it there's an option to I just
texted it to you if you want to pull it
up before we go talk to our friend to
your sanki uh this this other company is
called a tribal social and this is their
mission statement to all the Trump
supporters who are accusing us of
censoring them on our social network we
don't censor any post our algorithms
simply filter out fake news bigotry and
hostility if you want to trend on our
Network your post must be factual and
free of bigotry if that's what you want
folks go on tribal social if you
actually like this course and exchange
of ideas and arguments back and forth
you know somebody may or may not agree
with you then you may want to stay on
Twitter I like what yesterday Ricky
Gervais retweeted a clip from uh The
Late Late Show the guy that got in
trouble last week for the restaurant
James Corden and James Corden said
listen I I as if Twitter didn't suck
enough Elon Musk found a way to make it
suck even more to charge 20 a month he
says but let me talk to the people on
the other side he says you know what
Twitter is like sometimes did you see
this or not I thought the way he
explained it was awesome he says you
know what Twitter is like here's what
Twitter's like Twitter's like somebody
goes posts a poster of guitar lessons in
New York New York City and a person goes
up to it and screams and I cannot
believe you post the poster for guitar
lessons what about people who love piano
he says just walk past the poster if you
don't like the poster walk past it and
then the other guy's like and then if
you post piano what about people who
don't have hands that can't play the
piano dude just don't look at the poster
so it was so funny listening to both
sides of the argument what James was
saying but I'm excited about what musk
is doing quite frankly the fact that
there's so many unknowns what this guy
is going to be doing is interesting I
cannot wait to see what happens to it
but with that being said we have our
friend here from Sankey research how you
doing
a bit rough okay A bit rough tell us why
it's a bit rough what's happening yeah
you know what happened yesterday what
happened I mean you're talking about the
Liz trust story
Halloween uh Halloween parade in West
Village oh so that's a little bit of eye
makeup on you might see which is uh from
last night I I should share a photo of
it you got a little bit of static when
you're speaking can can you do that
without that mic or no because that mic
has given us a little bit of static
maybe if he can do it with the computer
mic it may be a little bit better I
don't know if you know how to do that or
not it's kind of high risk
um let's see how it goes
uh okay I mean we'll just work with that
right now just get into the question due
to time that we have and we'll keep it
brief but you you said it's still the
same you saw the story with Liz trust
may have a problem did Russia hack her
phone a story came out by Daily Mail on
Sunday claimed that former foreign
secretary former foreign secretary and
prime minister Liz trust private cell
phone was hacked by Foreign agents
suspected of working for the Kremlin and
that the hack was discovered during the
conservative party leadership campaign
that took place through the summer
foreign agents were able to intercept
messages sent to sent by the soon to be
prime minister about the war in Ukraine
in a tweet published on Sunday kim.com
the German Finnish entrepreneur and
activist who founded megaplod mega
upload on an online file hosting service
that was shut down by the US government
claimed that the Russians knew the
British government had a hand in the
north stream explosions because of a
message sent by trust from her personal
iPhone to Secretary State Anthony
blinken apparently 10 minutes after the
attack the the what do you call it the
explosion her saying it's done so what
are your opinions about these stories
I'm sure you're following it closely
my reaction when it first happened was
that this is this is a false flag type
operation that this has been blown up by
the Polish by the UK Special Forces
whatever because they couldn't see any
interest in Putin blowing up one of his
own weapons you know now there's an
alternate Theory which is that he's
deliberately showing you know what
economic Havoc he could wreak if he
wanted to
essentially threatening NATO because the
Baltic Sea where the explosion happened
is just about the most heavily defended
uh NATO sea right it's swarming with
NATO
so the question is how did the Russians
get in there and do it or did NATO do it
themselves it was as you know the
pipeline was blown up on the day
that the Baltic pipeline started
delivering to Poland
um you know so it was it was very
strange timing to say the least and as I
said I just couldn't see a reason why
Putin would do that to himself
strategically so unless you're just
double thinking so that he could accuse
the west of doing it so that he could
attack the West more I mean it's crazy
but you know what do you know so look
this is this is your role again if you
don't mind take 20 seconds just just
tell the audience your background uh
what you did so they know because you've
been back here now three or four times
with us if you don't mind just letting
people know what your background is and
then let us know the following so are
you saying there is a possibility that
lives trust knew and she was involved
with helping blinking you think there is
a possibility of that so one if you
don't mind giving us your background and
then two is there a possibility that
happened
what's it Lucy's yeah that's what I'm
saying my background is I've been an
online analyst for 30 years since Saddam
invaded Kuwait in 1990 uh you know in
sort of competition terms for about
three straight years I was the number
one ranked oil analyst on Wall Street
working for Deutsche Bank and then I've
been at a couple of boutiques I was at a
Japanese bank and now I have my own firm
so it's doing an energy analysis I I
appreciate that so just so for the
audience to know this is not just
somebody that uh you know had a hardcore
Halloween party till late night last
night that's telling us what's going on
here with the the issue with UK Russia
and blinken so if this is true and this
is verified how how ugly is this how bad
is this and how will they you know how
do how bad you think things can be if
there is credibility behind the story
well look you know this the fog of War
we don't know but what's tragic is that
when this all started because I think
Putin made a huge mistake and
particularly his military performed
absolutely abysmally so now he's in a
jam and he can't back down so that's a
nightmare I mean we had Security
Consultants on our on our call or we do
a weekly cool like you guys with you
know top clients and
the the fear was that he was going to
Aleppo they said if this is a quagmire
which it will be he's going to Aleppo
Ukraine which is to say in Aleppo which
is one of the most uh significant cities
in the world historically and culturally
in Syria the Russians just bonded to the
ground you know they just wasted it
and so what they're doing now which is
absolutely tragic and horrific is
they're essentially just taking down
Ukraine to dust you know and it's just a
nightmare so there's that
for the worst I think the feeling is
that Biden has actually managed this
okay you know he hasn't crossed any red
lines he's kept the pressure on Putin
you know we just don't know how far
Putin will go he's threatening nuclear
which obviously is terrifying but he may
just not be able to take that final step
I asked the state department you know
can he just hit a big red button
and they said no you know there is a
chain of command on nuclear so he has to
have at least three people agree to use
it and and the guy by the way added and
you know we looked at this very closely
uh because of Trump I was like oh great
so uh there is a chain of command and
you can't just hit a big red button but
it's obviously terrifying it's a bad
situation man bad Paul gas prices going
up going down staying flat what do you
think is going to happen with gas prices
due to this what we call gas which is
natural gas is under a lot of pressure
so that's natural gas that you use you
know for heating homes and everything
there's too much Supply in the US
actually interestingly so even though
European gas prices are very very high
we don't we don't have a problem here
right now the gas price is under a lot
of pressure the gas price at the pump
the gasoline price uh we think although
it's going back to we're servicing 120
brand by next
um driving season which was is going to
be May 2023 right now it's printing uh
let me see here around 95
uh it's 94.38 right now so we think
there's it's going back to 120 a barrel
and unfortunately that's going to make
the gasoline price go back up again
because there's fundamentally a two-fold
problem that the president frankly
doesn't seem to understand at all number
one is this
not enough oil supply and using the
Strategic petroleum reserve for oil
supply is obviously unsustainable and
that will end towards the end of this
year so you're going to lose a million
barrels a day of Supply from emergency
storage by the end of this year
and secondly there's not enough refining
capacity so that keeps gasoline prices
very tight relative to crude and again
the president simply just doesn't seem
to understand this but that's
essentially the problem and the reason
you've shut down a lot of refineries is
that you're worried about emissions and
refineries generate huge emissions so
again he doesn't seem to understand that
you shut down refineries because of
environmental pressure from the
government but if you put all those
things together I'm afraid it looks like
gasoline prices are going to stay pretty
elevated got it Paul thank you so much
for your time appreciate you have a good
one again thanks for coming on
take care bye-bye uh by the way if this
if this story is real
if this story is real and he's saying
it's real what do you mean it's done
and blinking you're texting it how do
you process that whole concept of 10
minutes after
the explosion happened she texts blink
and saying it's done that's very
confusing
how do you process it down I I think
there's a chess game that's played in
the international Arena that is beyond
the narratives that that we see
um and something that that he just
brought up like about the natural gas
United States
um you know where Canada gets its
natural gas from the United States you
know how much natural gas they get from
the United States all of it you know so
we are we are OPEC to Canada national
natural gas and so when you look at the
reason I bring that up that's not a
stray statistic if you really step back
and look at the chess game that is the
world energy Market it's not as simple
as as well OPEC is a bunch of people
that turn the spigot on turn the spigot
off raise the price up or not listen to
what he was just saying he when he was
talking about it uh the prices he said
Brent there's three crude bases that
that are meaningful the United States
one is Middle East light Suite then
there's Brent or North Sea as it's
called and then there's also North
Dakota and the thing they call WTI West
Texas intermediate which comes out of
Permian Basin there's all of these
markets of fuel that are everywhere and
when you step back the the geopolitical
forces that are behind this are so much
different than we see at the average
level it would not surprise me that in
the chess game of Putin that what
basically what we would World War II
speaking here the Allies did was to say
you know what we're going to hit the
pipeline because it's going to cause
this this this this this this and this
and there you go and you know in the
meantime you know the president speaks
out the other side of his mouth because
if you don't think we knew about that or
winked at it you don't understand the
power of the United States on a military
stage around the world if you don't
think we winked at that number one and
then two days later what is Biden doing
I'm gonna put a tax on there for this
windfall tax on all these oil companies
really why don't you backtrack some of
the political donations of the American
Energy Consortium and I think it's just
a bigger chess game than people
understand but you know who knows the
truth about this like there's probably
only one person likely I mean that
actually knows the truth and that's
Putin either he ordered this or he
didn't
so if he ordered it he knows what's
going on but if he didn't give this
order he knows that there's some some
stuff foul stuff that somebody smells in
Denmark right something rotten in
Denmark some singers yeah so ultimately
he knows what's going on here I mean who
know I don't know if there's been any
did Paul Sankey basically say he
believes that this was
the hands of the British via America via
the EU what have you is that what he
kind of said so I believe I believe it
because it helps Baltic and it helps it
helps neutralize Putin because now Putin
has to do two things one you know whose
pipeline is that
um
who owns Nordstrom
Russia Russians and the Germans yeah
what did we just do
we turned off the cash register on
Nordstrom
they're not delivering and so they're
not getting paid
meanwhile the Baltic pipeline is on so
I'm saying you got to step back and look
at this like in three dimensions it's
not hard but it takes time right and
this is Putin's Soul Big Money Maker
like what's the famous phrase about
Russia that Russia is really just a gas
station masquerading as a country
so if you cut off their
money supply oil supply
you know there goes their revenue so who
knows what actually is happening here
but it would be a
a gangster ass move by the the British
if that's exactly what happened so I'm
listening to this and it's just making
me curious about you know the midterms
are going to come and go and then the
focus is going to shift very quickly to
the presidential election and I'm just
curious how much of that presidential
election
how much do voters care about these very
specific issues we're talking about
about oil supply which comes down to
drilling which the Biden Administration
has stood against in numerous instances
how much do they care about lifting
regulations on the refineries which
would then increase the capacity of
those refineries and how much do they
care about where does the voting public
stand on involvement in this foreign
policy stuff liberals you know for a
long time claim to be
non-interventionists now I see them all
with Ukrainian flags all over there you
know bios and they're wanting us to give
more Aid to Ukraine which in turn is
deepening our involvement in that whole
situation I see mostly conservatives
saying get out this is none of our
business you know becoming more
non-interventionist which is why by the
way a guy like Trump won in the in his
election to begin with because he was
relatively non-interventionist and
conservatives are more
non-interventionist than people realize
because when they think of conservatives
they think of you know the Liz Chinese
and the on McCain's and that's not
reflective of what the conservative
voter looks like in large part but I'm
just curious how much this is going to
come into play because some of it is
directly related to economy it's
directly related to economy and security
which are the two issues that we've
really been talking about throughout
this whole podcast so maybe this all
comes front and center and rather than
having a largely domestic policy
conversation it becomes much more of a
foreign policy conversation for for
those that are going to be running for
the next time around what people don't
understand is as I felt that there is a
far left agenda that really just wants
to neutralize the United States and to
bring upon this you know this
liberal World equality and globalism
pure and so when you put pipelines
across the Midwest United States which
they canceled when you and by the way
everybody he's on the news about the
drilling permits right nobody sees
anything anything about their finery
permits it doesn't matter how much oil
you have if you can't heat it up and
turn it into Aviation gas kerosene
Diesel and gasoline and nylon so if you
can't if you can't refine it then you
can't do all these things and if you
take a look at the reality of what's up
there do you remember when North Dakota
had a real economic boom it's when the
Saudis artificially kept the price of
oil too high and what happened was if
that's everybody was moving to North
Dakota because if the price of a barrel
was that high then that's the price they
have to work with to get the heat into
the Earth to extract the Shale oil when
the price comes back down and I think it
was sixty dollars that if if uh crude on
a national basis on a global basis goes
below 60 Suddenly It's not economically
viable to pull Shale oil so what you do
is you pause and I can turn it back on
when the price is there the other side
is Anwar what's up in um Alaska if we
were to drill and put pipelines in you
and this will shock you it is five to
seven years the full energy Independence
and that's right and we would have more
clout than Venezuela and UAE put
together on a global stage to export
crude who and by the way what happens
then the power and elevation and stature
of the United States as a and the
potential to be a bully you know goes up
and all the globalists are like we can't
have that happen so they don't want
drilling they don't want permitting and
they don't want pipelines this is a big
chess game and this is all what's going
there and I think it's I you know this
is the part that that drives me really
well Jed back to your uh initial
question like how much does the American
voter care about these essentially
nuanced discussions about oil and and
Shale and burning no zero they care
about the price at the pump that's it
like I just learned something from
bizdoc and part of me is like oh that's
very interesting all of the above can
bring your price to the pump yeah nobody
cares that's my point you know they care
about 175 no they don't care about all
the prices at the pump they don't care
well you gotta understand that Anwar and
when you heat it up and they're like
dude are you talking about like just is
gas eight dollars a gallon or is it
three dollars a gallon that's all I care
about and that's the American voter so I
think though that the that there is a
growing part of the population of the
American voter that cares about the idea
that I talk about all the time that the
current destruction is intentional and
we shifted that over from when we talk
about the system The Matrix whatever you
want to call it we tell talk about the
coveted agenda and that was largely
lockdowns that was mandates that was the
way that Society was crippled by the
reaction to covid not covet itself and
now that has changed and shifted over by
the globalists of the world hi Bill
Gates if you're watching to The Climate
agenda and now that climate agenda is
going to be first and foremost as a
means to [ __ ] society and that's
what's going to hit these refineries
that's what's going to hit prevent
drilling you know what you're talking
about about Anwar I researched that
extensively when I first got into
politics because that was the stuff that
Sarah Palin was talking about they dove
in and went right after her primarily
because she was an expert on energy
Independence had been working on that
for years and she was deeply threatening
to the system as a result of that and
her expertise in that particular area so
I think this is the new topic that does
become relevant this climate agenda
because it's being utilized by the folks
at the top to [ __ ] society and I
think that because these prices do
affect their everyday life do affect
what their they're paying at the pump do
affect you know say do affect National
Security do affect then the safety of
themselves and their families I think
that if you can make that argument
tangible to people and it's not
something happening out there in the
world it's something happening right
here in their hands in their home in
their backyard I do think people will be
very very plugged into that and I would
advocate for a republican candidate
whoever it is Ron DeSantis Donald Trump
whoever it may be to zero in on that
climate agenda because that is going to
be the biggest Force for Destruction
that the left is going to utilize to
criminal Society you asked about two
things if people care about oil prices
and the war did you see two weeks ago or
three weeks ago when everybody at a AOC
Town Hall was railing on Alexandria
ocasio-cortez for voting for nuclear war
all these progressives turning around
and flipping on AOC I think that is very
exemplary and a Bellwether that listen
these progressives don't care about oil
they don't care about gas prices they
don't give a [ __ ] they want to get rid
of oil anyway they want to drive their
Tesla to work or what have you you know
what they do care about they care about
new clear War the progressive caucus put
a bill forward to pull out of Ukraine
and to stop funding Ukraine and you know
what they did they withdrew it because
they got too much pressure from The
Establishment Democrats you had AOC
Rashida Talib ilhan Omar the squad put
forward a bill to stop funding Ukraine
and they pulled it back their their
Progressive base is going to flip on
them so the left is shooting themselves
in the foot not on oil but on the
Ukraine war you're going to see these
progressives turn around and say no I'm
done it's not a hard argument hey
America needs energy Independence and
you need a two dollar gas at the pump
that's what we need you can connect
those docks for the average voter let's
transition to the next story Hebrew got
like 10 minutes left before we wrap up
did you guys hear did you hear about the
fact that Zuckerberg's net worth
declined he lost a hundred billion
dollars in his Netflix I asked you about
that like is that true and you're like
oh this happened yeah I didn't believe
it he lost a hunt put up the story from
Fortune he lost a hundred billion
dollars uh here's a story from Vice
Facebook's Monopoly is imploding before
our eyes for years the definition of
success from many Tech employees has
been getting a job at Fang companies
like Facebook Amazon Apple Netflix
Google but there's evidence that
Facebook is on the uh uh uh here give me
this word here precipice uh precipitous
precipice
precipice of dropping out of the group
out of this group through years of sheer
mismanagement of failure to innovate
setting money on fire in pursuit of
metaverse that seemingly no one wants a
vulnerable business model that apple is
squarely taking aim at and upstart
competitors like Tick Tock that the com
uh company seemingly has no answer to in
a little over one year the company has
shared nearly you ready folks 800
billion dollars of its market cap nearly
a trillion dollars wow with the Lion's
Share of that coming these past eight
months reality Labs Facebook's metaverse
fantasy team burned through four and a
half billion dollars in 2019 6.6 billion
in 2020 and 10.1 billion dollars in 2021
that's a total of 20 one billion dollars
another 9.4 billion dollars in losses
has been realized in 2022 bring in
reality Labs operating losses to north
of 31 billion dollars and that's
Facebook Tom when you see the story
with Facebook and Zuck what do you think
about is this somebody said the other
day on Twitter I don't know who it was
they said look now that muskbot Twitter
can somebody buy Facebook Okay can
somebody go out there and buy Facebook
how bad is it at Facebook right now I'd
like to apologize to everybody for my
deep energy analysis and I will thank
you for comments that I should keep it
more simple and I'll take it right back
to simple in this Facebook is not
getting consumers from the new
generation so old Facebook think of it
as a gas powered engine Zuckerberg
thinks that metaverse is his EV that the
old product is not going to be there
long term and it's not growing in ad
value and that's not growing in
customers especially the Generation Z
Anew so he has to bet on something else
and he's sitting there like Thomas
Edison saying call me crazy if you will
but I gotta invent something else that's
going to bring me Revenue tomorrow and
it is the metaverse so I think it's that
simple what he's looking at by the way
did you did you hear what Jim Cramer did
on Mad Money a couple days ago he almost
cried on the already apologized oh he
actually did cry he cried saying I
apologize he was talking to David Faber
for telling people that Facebook is a
good investment and Facebook stocks not
done very well so it's been it's been a
little bit challenging but he was crying
yeah you can see the interview go it
just goes the show nobody knows what
direction the market or a stock is going
Jim Cramer who's the quote-unquote
expert about everything comes to stock
market Finance is now crying on air
because of his wrong speculation that's
why it's so hard to do that week for
CNBC because uh Deirdre Bossa is that
her name dear to Bossa um she also
apologized because she got completely
Hoodwinked on the uh the the fake
Twitter engineer story so it was a tough
week
well a couple things about Facebook
because I obviously I'll ask young
people questions I'm like are you on
Facebook they're like no I don't like
once you saw your grandma or your mom on
Facebook yeah I'm out I'm off this
platform what am I talking about here
and
and rightfully so the direction like are
your daughters on Facebook uh no no
because you're on it Tom nobody's trying
to hang out with you bro
that was a joke so just put your your
daughters are not honest you can stop
yelling because you're absolutely
correct that's what I'm saying like the
point is that like your daughters aren't
trying to affiliate with their father or
grandfather on Facebook because it's not
a thing but the pivot that Facebook is
not cool or interesting exactly Facebook
but you are so don't take that as a
knock the the
um
the the pivot to meta
when was at the height of the crypto
Market the height of Bitcoin the height
of Dogecoin the hype of ethereum and
then we've seen what's happened with the
crash of crypto nfts have lost what 90
of their value over the last six 12
months so like talk about timing like
guys great idea we're gonna change
Facebook to meta crypto's the hottest
thing in the world we're doing the
metaverse thing
like we've seen what's happened Italian
I don't know if you can pull this up I
would love to know in 2020
the height of Zuckerberg's wealth like
where was he on the top 20 list maybe
number four or five and where he is
today I would love to add him on that
also you can lay over the political
environment because remember a lot of
Democrats blamed Zuckerberg for not
being tough enough and allowing the
Trump election to take place with all
the shenanigans so he ends up in front
of Congress on safety issues on protocol
issues on foreign intervention so the
old Facebook was Under Fire and the old
Facebook isn't getting new cons
consumers as you just pointed out from
my daughter's generation so guess what
the entrepreneur that Zuckerberg says
I'm inventing my way out and I think
it's that simple and the pain they're
going through the reason that Facebook
is dropping isn't because he's investing
in metaverse the reason Facebook is
dropping is because ad revenue is
dropping subscribership is dropping for
sure all those consumers aren't there so
while the thing is going down Zuckerberg
is not getting credit will it work I
don't know if metaverse is going to work
I don't think it will but he's not
getting credit for being the
entrepreneur trying to invent himself
out of the hole well Pat let me tee this
up for you you posted something I don't
know a couple weeks ago you're saying
like if you look at the Fortune 500
companies from 1950 like how many are
still in it today great point and it was
like 50 of companies I don't remember
but like just because a company is the
top dog does not guarantee that they
will be the top dog 10 20 50 years from
now what were those do you remember
those six set like 70 60 of Fortune 500
companies from 1970 are no longer even
in business so just insane yeah which is
insane so look but we're on this right
but but I will tell you I don't think
it's because zuck's not being Innovative
I don't think it's because he's you know
but he went all in on nfts and meta and
it backfired right as great of a product
they may be producing with 31 billion
dollars into it
the market said no we're not going to it
may happen in the next 10 years it may
happen in the next five years it's just
not happening right now due to where the
where the markets and Tyler just pulled
this up in 2020 he was the fifth richest
person in the world uh this may be 2021.
okay even 2021 exactly so conservatives
also don't trust Facebook generally
speaking nobody because of the collusion
that happened between uh Zuckerberg and
fauci and the whole team on that stuff
they don't trust that but I always say
Facebook reminds me of cable news it's
like I hate to say it this way but the
audience is is dying I mean they're very
old these are very old people so they
have to like re-energize they ha you
have to get those Tick Tock people to
want to come over to Facebook for some
reason and why I feel like Twitter has
its own brand it's where you go to kind
of have that debate the discussion I
totally get the appeal of Twitter I also
get the appeal of tick tock because it's
like these little sound bites I get the
Young Generation that has no attention
spam what is Facebook doing really
that's unique and why last word let me
just say this though let me just say
this still in two years do not be
surprised whoever gets elected in 2024
2025 if they choose to ban Tick Tock
then in 2025 the app that could take off
is Instagram and Instagram will get all
the people from Tick Tock that'll move
over and by the way most of our Clips do
better on Instagram right now than
they're doing on Tick Tock if those
people move over Facebook will be back
up again but in the next two years uh
it'll have a lot to do with somebody
taking down Tick Tock in the states give
it a last word and a tip of the hat to
certain types of leadership
um who is responsible for the 10-year
run at Facebook who is responsible for
the economic plan
for the 10-year Cheryl Sandberg that is
correct it was recently departed that's
right so I said a certain type of
leadership there was to one of the most
influential best I don't agree with her
book everything on lean in but there's
parts of it that I love in terms of my
daughters but she came out there female
in leadership at the top of tech and
drove this thing and a lot of the
mistakes and things that happened she
and Zuckerberg had a falling out so
let's face it she was retired let's
understand what happened here
um in the face of the stuff that was
going on but he also lost his number two
that drove the company to where it was
yeah and Pat has a very good point about
let's not underplay the fact that he
changed his entire company name very
risky entire brand to the metaverse yeah
he changed his entire company to meta
not like hey this is a branch of what we
do no he's the entire company is meta
now he's telling every engineer in the
country well this is it we're at the end
of the podcast uh home team podcast
today I hope you guys enjoyed it for the
people that tune in there's a lot of you
guys that prefer this then you prefer
the interviews there's some of you guys
that love the interviews but some of you
guys that just prefer us talking about
current events I think we're doing it
again on Thursday if I'm not mistaken
possibly you know we may have a surprise
from somebody we're working on for some
major interviews that'll be coming out
soon jet I know our interview is going
live Friday Thursday okay Thursday on
yeah on my show did I be alive I
interviewed this guy right here and we
talk about high value men we talk about
marriage I dug into all the juicy stuff
you know I did so yeah push the envelope
we had a good time and by the way
forty thousand Subs is growing can't
wait for that to get to a million Subs
in no time Adam what's your next uh show
you got coming up Thursday sauce cast 4
P.M yes sir 4 P.M okay having said that
folks we'll see you guys again in two
days if you enjoyed this podcast give us
a sub at 500 000 Subs we're gonna do
something really special maybe even
invite someone of you guys to come to
our new set that we're producing with
300 people there but we're gonna do that
at 500 000 Subs so if you enjoy the
podcast give us a sub uh uh support the
content that we're producing here take
care everybody bye bye bye